being dropped it will happen to us all
at some point so negotiating a pain with
a measure of reason belongs to the art
of living a number of tips suggests
themselves firstly don't attempt to
minimize what's happened being brave has
no place here allow yourself into so
much room so much time so many
melancholic songs hot baths and
indulgent meals you eventually bore
yourself back into an appetite for life
secondly believe them when they said it
don't imagine that their past sweetness
and kind words provides any covert
indications of future commitment kill
any remaining hope yourself if they
didn't quite have the courage to do so
themselves don't imagine that anyone can
love on command the capacity to feel
attracted lies outside the will it isn't
a question of them not trying hard
enough
remove morality from it they were not
being bad for not loving and no were you
good for wanting them you were both on
search for pleasure but took you down
different and conflicting routes our
conscious Minds ride like tiny boats on
the swells of unconscious psychoanalytic
and biological seeds so don't turn this
into a morality tale
they acted weirdly around the break-up
not because they were bad or indeed
unsure they just felt terribly guilty
because they're nice which doesn't
though
that they want you many of us are
predisposed to think especially well of
people who don't want us it feeds into
our reserves of self-hatred but this
isn't Romanticism it's an illness the
true challenge is the Scot being so
revolted by people who do in fact want
us and so admiring of those who don't
think back to when you rejected people
you didn't hate them or regret them the
chief emotions were embarrassment and
pity don't connect up the rejection with
everything you fear and hate about being
you don't accuse them of cowardice
don't exaggerate their qualities don't
insist on their uniqueness don't offer
them sex in the hope of changing their
mind don't imagine that people can fall
back in love with someone at a pity or
of guilt and don't defensively maintain
that they had a fear of intimacy just
try to love and have a few rounds of
casual sex if that helps but above all
don't keep thinking of the end of this
relationship as tragically sad the only
good relationship the only relationship
worth mourning would be one to which two
people desperately wanted to belong and
this wasn't in the end despite all the
promising signs that kind of
relationship at all
you
you